there's a presence that's missing
without jake packing up and moving back
to la how can we build him some sort of
presence some sort of avatar that will
let him do his job in a physical sense
as well
[Music]
we're gonna actually take the first step
into bringing jake back into the studio
oh what ups huh
[Music]
today is a very special day because jake
is in the studio from texas he's been
here for a day and i'm already noticing
a palpable productivity increase now you
guys might just know jake from the
sponsored segments you know brandi
o'daniel as we call him a lot of people
don't realize he's our producer a lawyer
he does a lot of like the back end stuff
you don't see on camera i mean really
what he does allows everything else to
happen here but now that he's in texas
it's like there's a presence that's
missing things have gotten a little bit
lacks since jake went to texas people
are getting soft it's no no surprise
that smash brothers is popular and you
know if you ask a couple people in the
studio they'd say too popular
imagine if jake was here all the time
we could probably put out at least
another video a week
so the question is you know without jake
packing up and moving back to la how can
we build him some sort of presence some
sort of avatar that will let him do his
job in a physical sense as well about a
week ago i think technology got there
you know elon musk announced his uh
tesla bot i think we're there so what
we're gonna do today is jake and i we're
gonna actually take the first step into
bringing jake back into the studio and
we're gonna kind of figure out how to
actually make this a reality
what is a jake what who is jake watson
let's start with the essence because the
essence will inform our purpose he's a
leader so he needs to you know have some
sort of authority you wear some genes
always that say you know i'm not afraid
of some hard work
positive affirmation
present
in the daily happenings of the studio
and i think that's absolutely critical
in our design here like if it if it
doesn't have my presence then the whole
thing's a wash i think
we're gonna need some servo controlled
arms yes and opposable thumbs
[Music]
this hat will house it'll have like a
little hole for the camera
sheriff sheriff star on there yeah it's
gonna need a high resolution camera 4k
streaming
a shirt with velcro on it and we can put
different brands on with the velcro oh
my god
that's a great idea
the blaring alarm will be for when smash
has gone on for too long or just when
it's gone on at all you know we'll just
cut it out all together yeah yeah i mean
people need breaks though sometimes you
know it's pretty healthy for breaks
like smash is good for the morale you
know like once in a while
i'm not sure you really understand
what we're trying to build here yeah
let's move on let's move on it needs to
know how to do business and crunch
numbers
yes
yes let's just add a snow cone maker to
it what's a happier thing than a snow
cone and you can eat it at your desk i
like raspberry snow cones
led lights yeah but then also on top of
that it records everything that everyone
says all the time
so you want to record everything yeah
and then it's like listen i'm listening
it's present don't you get it
okay yeah well let's move on but we'll
definitely add the recording thing all
the time video it's cool
let's move on
this whole thing together no matter how
much it costs we'll be able to recoup it
probably in a very short amount of time
and i think now is the perfect time to
do it because sam and nico are out this
week so they're not here to tell me not
to spend this money which i think is
really important because when they come
back they'll see how much money i've
saved i'm pretty happy with this i think
what we need to do
is bring down nat who's our resident
maker she knows a lot about the tech
that's actually going to make this
happen
and i think she'll be able to actually
give us a tangible maybe dollar cost and
time frame for like how long it's going
to take her to make it
what we have here
is going to change everything
[Music]
[Applause]
60 frames per second 4k yeah and
recording literally everything all the
time audio visual lit everything if
there's if we can record anything else
let's record it not everything but
some things one note on size kind of
tall guy you know six feet tall about so
we just figured let's make it 12. 12
feet tall if we don't fear the robot
version of you how are we going to get
anything done so zero productivity loss
and pretty much a whole lot of
productive future
i think i can do this i'm gonna run the
numbers and get back to these guys uh
because this is gonna be
a really cool build
i think if anyone can do this it's nat
i've seen some of the stuff she's built
she knows how to model she knows 3d
printing she knows like electronics this
is
completely ridiculous this is stupid
sam nico said they don't want me using
the hambone jar for
anything but what really is this money
for
i'm just going to give them just a
ridiculously high number
we've got like almost 20 dollars in here
probably gonna cover us
yes okay got a number
give it to a stranger i'm gonna give it
to you gay with all the considerations
there's a lot of things going on here
um i here's
here's the number i'm thinking of um 69
420. um
is this in uh yen
it's in bitcoin
listen this is the price of living in
the future
what if we take out the snow cone
machine
okay well i got to think about this um
you know when i said that we could spend
anything on this
anything was
you know it was rhetorical
plan b
plan b
[Music]
so
[Music]
gotta go with the flow sometimes you get
hired and the person that hires you
lives here and then
they decide to leave in the middle of
your career you're talking about jake
baby
i know you guys think there's this huge
rivalry and there might be and i'm
coming for his job and i might be but it
wasn't always like this you know me and
jake used to work together all the time
and then he just left one thing that i
know about jake is that jake loves
squarespace it's crazy to think that
someone just up and leaves something so
important to them today's video is
sponsored by you guessed it squarespace
it's jake's desk who
sometimes it is sometimes it's not but
i'm here to talk about squarespace
squarespace has a huge array of
award-winning beautiful templates that
is super easy to put onto your website
making it look like a professional did
it there's a bunch of different layouts
that are super easy to use depending on
your business type you just go through
and choose which one is right for you
squarespace offers you a huge array of
analytic tools you can see all the
traffic that's coming to your page you
can see who's coming and going sort of
like how jake comes and goes from texas
to l.a jake and i used to contribute
around here equally but now we have to
rely solely on squarespace's multiple
contributor tools it's all customizable
from the website manager you can connect
all of your social media accounts to
squarespace and not only can you do that
but it reformats to every single type of
social media platform if you post one
thing on your website it will format to
twitter it'll format to instagram to
facebook automatically if you're ready
to take control of your website go to
squarespace.com corridor crew or click
the link in the description below to get
10 off your first website or domain
oh what up son what up
there it is so listen i'm glad you're
here man you know as i briefly explained
to you i've got this problem right i'm
in texas the people are here in the
studio and i i need somebody to
represent me
here in the studio you know you are a
class act when it comes to your
abilities to portray characters on
screen the best thing we can do
is to have you just sort of absorb my
mannerisms my personality right like
everything that do the way that i
interact
and then start to become me okay right
yeah the less that i'm here the less
productive the studio is i mean usually
when i research a character you know i
really like to to like find the clothing
what you do on a regular day basis yeah
so let's start there i think it's time
to give you a jake over
these are my favorite pair of pants
right here you can see i wear them a lot
mm-hmm i mean life
i'm known to wear the corridor hat from
time to time i really get it
i think this is going great so far i'm
really excited to introduce him to the
final piece of this avatar but i think
in the meantime you know we'll just get
him in these clothes get him comfortable
really just observe what it's like day
in the life of jake
oh [ __ ]
it's jake it's actually working
it's actually working pretty well
welcome thank you for the sponsored
segment by squarespace
how was this [ __ ] son it's working great
yeah yes okay great okay come here let's
come into the light what do you think
yeah this one this one
brett you're starting to really look the
part but there's one more thing you
gotta be the part okay so what's
happening right now is that there's a
smash game going on
and what i usually do around this time
when the game's been going on for too
long i just show up and i start
harassing everybody telling them to get
back to work does this happen regularly
yeah this happens like every day damn it
we can't let that happen right
guys
what are we uh
what are we doing here guys hey nat yeah
you know what you've been wasting a lot
of time here to put that controller down
and get back to work from behind it
literally looks exactly like
damn
what's up do you like working here
yes i was playing this game and i'm like
oh god jake's here
but it was red
dude
i think it's brett it's not breath
what about this makes it feel like it's
not me
in the face the face face what about the
face it's not you're not jake's face
i mean it's a tough job you know i mean
from my experience so far from today no
one really listens to you
i think there's just really there's just
one more part we need to go over that's
really gonna just complete the illusion
the final part of the costume
oh my
god yes dude oh my god that's something
we made this contraption
it's very realistic yeah i it's uh super
realistic should i uh should i put you
on i mean yeah
i don't feel i don't know son this is a
scary moment i feel like this is the
final transformation
oh my god dude what's up jake
hey so this video is going to be
sponsored by squarespace
this is amazing dude yeah i think we
should go into the studio and see if
they even recognize that anything is
different at all
jake you want to tap in with dean yeah
i'd love to hop in with dean let's go
see what he's up to
hey dean man how are you
doing all right man what are you what
are you what are you chopping away at
there are you've been eating a lot of
salt your head looks a little like
puffed up no not any more than normal i
mean just the normal amount of salt i've
been working out a little bit more and
um you know just really just excited to
be here in the studio with you guys i
know i don't get to do that every day
but i think um that will change yeah i'm
really i'm really hoping this is the new
you
hey so good to see you man you're here
with me right now aren't you yeah i'm
just checking in to see how the edits
going we got another day or so we're
going to give them a little bit longer
react sessions so we're excited about
that i'm super excited for that that's
great yeah man it's gonna be good what's
going on over on this side of the studio
let's go see what griffin is up to man i
love that guy
dude hey i saw that fingerboard video
that you and daniel put together it
looks like a lot of fun man do you mind
if i try it right here with your little
set here's my own personal board right
there
oh man this brings me back
you know whatever
[Music]
that was amazing i'm so glad i got to do
that thank you so
much jake what are you doing you look
good red
how was your trip up north
i mean my trip started off great it
didn't end that great but you know i
can't complain oh
everything okay i know i got in a car
accident uh i got rear ended not my
fault though i just i gotta wait three
months for it to get fixed jeez man i'm
sorry to hear that i know how much you
love that car yeah so anyway how's it
going man what are you working on this
week
i'm i'm just it's going all right i'm
just
very intimidated by your presence your
inner pupillary distance is measured in
meters look i don't want you to be
intimidated by my presence i just
figured we can do some cool work at the
studio here together maybe i can sit
down next to you and we can work this
out
[Music]
yeah let's uh let's let's work on this
i'm working on uh how many solar panels
could power the world
okay yeah this is better
yeah this is this is
better do you want to go start filming
for that do you need me in any of the
scenes because i could be in any of the
scenes that you need
oh good i think uh you know what you
just take care of you know management
and running the business
all good high fives
[Music]
with any luck i can start to be here in
the studio every day do you think that
would be better yeah no i think i think
that would really raise morale around
here i always appreciate it man
no one even noticed that it was an
avatar version of me played by brett
it just goes to show you that people
don't notice things and as long as you
are there in spirit that's what really
matters
i cannot wait to be in the studio with
everybody and really just make a more
positive impact each and every day
it's going to be
great brett oh man it works
i'm sorry i you know i channeled every
you know all the things i've studied
about you for years yes
you know brett i i thought when this
started that i was actually gonna have
to fire you because you couldn't see um
but i think that uh
i think you're hired man um i mean i'll
have to check the schedule i can't come
in every day from like 10 to like 7 30.
um
we talked about it just being kind of
one day thing uh
i don't know i i've got a kind of a life
to
live so i don't know if i can
uh wear this
mask of you all all day you know
yeah um
i i apologize maybe i didn't think of
your life no that's okay i mean yeah we
all have lives to live you know but you
know how about every tuesday i come in
here every tuesday i'll wear it for you
really i'll do that for you every
tuesday
maybe egg every other tuesday
every other tuesday from here on out i
think so we'll play by ears really you
know we'll complain by year but i gotta
get going uh okay i'm gonna send you a
contract oh uh let's just hold on for
that for a bit and i'll se i'll get my
people to get you okay i'll be back
thanks for the the watch too
oh brett brett that's my watch and those
are my favorite pants
hey
hold on man we can make this work
we can make this work
i knew it was gonna end like this